Wide ranging survey on how
racism and discrimination
affect American life
finds that minorities
in this country
expect to face discrimination
when they seek health care.
They not only expected,
they prepare for it.
KFF, a nonprofit group
focused on health care
policy, says that many Hispanic,
black, Asian and American
Indian and Alaska Native adults in the US
believe they must modify
both their mindset and the way they look
to stave off potential mistreatment
during health care visits.
60% of black people surveyed,
52% of American Indian
and Native Alaskans,
51% of Hispanics, 42% of Asian
said that they prepare to hear insults
or they feel that they have to take care
extra care with their appearance
in order to be treated fairly.
At least some of the time.
Joining me now to talk about
this is Samantha Arteaga,
KFC's director of racial equity
and health policy.
Samantha, thank you for being with me.
This implicit bias does not
come as a surprise to some people,
but to those who are new to this.
Explain what you've learned
about the different ways
that whites and minorities
in this country
say that they experience health care
differently.
So overall,
I think the survey findings
really highlight
how persistent and prevalent
racism and discrimination
remain in the U.S.
today
and how those experiences
extend into health care,
affecting people's experiences,
seeking health care,
as well as ultimately their health
and well-being.
As you mentioned,
our survey findings highlight
how experiences
with racism
can affect people's experiences
even before they get
to the doctor's office
with them taking steps
to prepare for these visits.
Concerned about facing insults
from a provider or office staff and also
being extra careful
about their appearance
in order to be treated fairly.
But even when folks get into the health
care doctor's office, we see
them take being treated unfairly
more frequently
due to their race and ethnicity,
and also saying that they have
more certain
negative experiences
in the doctor's office
because of their race and ethnicity.
So things like a health care provider
not taking their concerns seriously,
not answering a question
or responding to a request,
blaming them for a health issue or not
prescribing pain medication
that they thought they needed.
You know, it's interesting
I found in this survey
is that the minority respondents
didn't think that it would be any better
if the health care providers
shared their race or ethnicity.
So this is not a
a white provider black patient.
It is the medical services in
the industry.
It is the medical profession
and the patient
as it relates to minorities.
Explain that a bit more.
Well, it's interesting, even though
survey respondents said that
they didn't think they would get better
care if they had a health care provider
who looked like them.
What we actually see
in the survey findings
is that when adults of color
have more visits
with a health care provider
who shares their racial
and ethnic background,
they report having
more frequent positive,
respectful interactions
with their health care provider.
So the survey findings
actually do
point to some potential opportunities
and benefit from increasing efforts to
improve the diversity
of the health care workforce.
But we also see that the survey findings
are pointing widely
to the importance of continued
training and education programs
to root out the bias and discrimination
that are reflected in the survey.
Yeah, and I think we take that
finding and mirror that against
what we see in some states,
specifically in Florida
with Governor Ron
DeSantis, who defunded DEA,
the Diversity,
Equity and Inclusion programs
at schools, at learning institutions,
de-funding the implicit
bias training at these places
so that any plan, any effort to lessen
at least what
we're seeing through this survey
in some states is really
facing some major challenges.
Overall, I think the survey findings
really point
to the importance
of continued action to address
racism and discrimination,
particularly in health care.
They show that racism and discrimination
are not just a social issue,
they are a health issue.
And beyond the findings
reflected in terms of impacts
on people's experiences
seeking health care,
they also highlight
the strong link between discrimination
and health and well-being.
So people who report more experiences
with discrimination
in their daily life,
which remains frequent,
are more likely to report
certain negative
health impacts
like increased feelings
of anxiety, depression and loneliness.
So there are health impacts
also tied to these experiences
with discrimination.
About more than I experience
saying discomfort.
It's about outcomes
for these communities as well.
Samantha Arteaga with
KFF, thank you so much.